bonjour à tous aujourd'hui à l'occasion
de la sortie de disney plus en france et
surtout parce qu'il n'ya maintenant plus
d'embargo pour en parler
j'aimerais que nous parlions d'une
petite série indépendante qui a fait
très peu parler d'elle j'ai nommé the
mandaloriennes star wars par le biais de
cette série a finalement fait son
véritable passage sur petit écran et la
série de demandes d'halloween promet
beaucoup pour l'avenir de la saga
j'aimerais que nous parlions ensemble
des potentielles futures intrigues qui
arriveront dans la saison 2 donc cela
sous-entend bien évidemment que je vais
devoir spoil la saison une donc vous
êtes prévenus bon je le répète à chaque
vidéo mais il me semble que c'est
important de le rappeler
au cours de cette vidéo je vais bien
évidemment vous proposer ma vision
totalement personnelle et subjective
je vous invite quant à vous à partager
vos visions et vos théories en
commentaire histoire que l'on débatte
tous ensemble dans la bienveillance
n'oubliez pas le petit pouce bleus et à
activer la cloche nous repartons
ensemble dans ce merveilleux univers
qu'est star wars avec trois théories que
je vous
[Musique]
je voulais mais je ne pensais pas que
par les deux mandats lauriane ce récit
complexe
la série a beau être avant tout
divertissante et courte cette dernière
ne révolutionne en rien le cinéma et
base mandat lauriane possède un
background énorme et le plus gros
mystère reste l'origine et le but du
rôle de baby you down déjà ce dernier
fait partie de la race du maître jedi
yoda que vous connaissez tous et c'est
une race qui a toujours été
volontairement caché par george lucas
himself
c'est une décision qui a été respectée
jusqu'à maintenant et nous savons
concrètement que très peu de choses sur
yoda et ses origines
d'où le fait que nous ne savons rien sur
l'enfant et que par rapprochement il
s'est fait appeler baby yoda par la
communauté ce que nous savons juste
c'est que c'est une race qui vit très
longtemps yoda avait à peu près 900 ans
à sa mort et baby yoda a déjà environ 50
ans mais également que c'est une race
qui est très sensible à la force
nul besoin de rappeler la puissance de
maître yoda ou même les démonstrations
de l'enfant durant la série du mandat
lauriane bref pour en revenir aux faits
le but qui semble finale instauré par la
série et que l'enfant soit ramené auprès
des siens ou bien que d'inge arin veille
sur lui jusqu'à sa majorité
on ne va pas se mentir la seconde option
va être compliqué vu sa longévité
là où j'aimerais vous amener et quant à
l'âge de l'enfant
ce dernier ayant plus de 50 ans dans ce
mandat lauriane cela signifie qu'il est
né à peu près neuf ans avant star wars 1
la menace fantôme
à cette époque il existait encore deux
personnages issus de la même race yoda
et y adhèrent alors je vous arrête tout
de suite bien que yoda était un homme
entre guillemets et il ya 2
femmes ils étaient tous deux dans les
plus hauts membres de l'ordre jedi
cela m'étonnerait fort qu'ils aient
rompu le règlement pour se caler deux
trois petits d'haïti comme ça le truc
c'est que voilà nous pourrions penser
que des bio da soit alors clone de yoda
ou possiblement d'oeil à dole étant
donné que la thématique des clones
faisait partie de la prélogie et même
avant on en revient toujours à la même
chose pourquoi yoda ou encore yade elle
aurait voulu se cloner ce n'est pas
logique par rapport aux codes des jedi
et au vu de leur place importante
je ne vois pas du tout yoda ou même la
deûle à un moment où tout allait bien
car oui 9 en avant la menace fantôme
tout semble aller normalement
bah il ou elle ferait naître un enfant
qu il cacherait à tous jusqu'à leur mort
la seule explication pour moi serait
palpatine très secret est obsédé depuis
son apprentissage aux côtés de pelé
guise sur la manipulation des midis clos
rien et la vie éternelle
en se déplaçant de corps en corps et ça
c'est une obsession qu'il détient depuis
avant la menace fantôme
mais ce n'est pas tout shiv ans s'est
également beaucoup sur les clones
je vous rappelle l'ordre 66 ou encore
tout simplement snoeck planifiant tous
ces coûts à l'avance et sachant qu'ils
étaient l'un des plus grands maîtres
jedi de tous les temps sidious aurait pu
tenter de recréer yoda ou de manipuler
les midis clos rien mais encore une fois
c'est une hypothèse qui ne se base que
sur très peu de chose au vu de
l'ancienneté de l'enfant il est possible
que disney souhaite tout simplement
développer un arc narratif qui avait été
ignoré et caché par lukas depuis tout ce
temps soit de mettre en lumière la race
de yoda la planète de l'espèce et leurs
liens avec la force une espèce très
mystérieuse et très puissante qui
pourrait faire vendre après tout
n'oublions pas que star wars repose
beaucoup sur du merchandising
pourquoi baby yoda et si mignon
prévu
l'univers est infinie l'espace c'est
grand et même si la saga a toujours
tourné autour des skywalker
il est enfin temps que ça s'arrête et
que l'on commence à compter d'autres
légendes c'est le cas ici avec la série
du mandat lauriane j'en suis sûr plus
qu'une simple garde d'enfants ou la
mission est de leur ramener à la maison
ou de veiller sur lui la syrie veut
mettre en lumière l'histoire des
mandaloriens ce n'est pas pour rien si
le héros principal en est un et qu'en
plus il y est la présence du darksiders
le sabre noir dans la conception des
films star wars et de la saga tout
entière il y a toujours eu une
symbolique de héros d'élus autour du
personnage principal que ce soit anakin
dans la prélogie nuque dans la trilogie
aux mêmes regrets dans la sienne ici
d'inge arin nous est présentée de la
même manière comme le meilleur des
chasseurs de primes
celui qui a réussi à ramener l'enfant et
qui a déjoué les plantes et interio ce
côté divin ou encore d'élus est encore
plus accentuée via l'épisode iv où ce
dernier va devenir le symbole du village
qu'il aura sauvé en compagnie de cars
abdoun
donc je vous le mets en 1010 jo rin va
monter en puissance et en estime
je vous explique tout d'abord revenons
au sabre laser noir
peut-être que certains d'entre vous ne
savent pas vraiment ce qu'il représente
plusieurs vidéos de chaîne dédiée on
parle très bien donc je vais me
contenter de vous résumer brièvement la
chose de sabre noir en gros est un sabre
qui fut créée par le tout premier
mandaloriens à être considérée par
l'ordre jedi tarvis là désolé ma
prononciation ce mandat lauriane est
même devenu le dirigeant des
mandaloriens à un moment donné et fut
très vénérés s'en suit plusieurs
péripéties après la mort de ce
personnage ou le sabre a beaucoup voyagé
de main en main péripéties que vous
pourrez retrouver notamment dans la
série clone wars ou rebels
bref ce qui nous intéresse ici est que
le sabre a fini par tomber dans les
mains de mof guider hawn un ancien
officier de l'anp pire ayant obtenu le
titre de mof soit une sorte de
gouverneur de lempire ou plus tôt
des vestiges de l'empiré pour en revenir
à dean djar in je pense que son arc son
but personnel se retrouvent ici très
dévoué au mandaloriens qui ont été
divisées et tué à cause des imperio
suite au non respect de la mission de
jean jouines le mandalorien va très
certainement affronter de nouveaux
guides et homme présenté comme un
chasseur d'exception une sorte de futurs
élus des mandaloriens il est possible
que dean soit le prochain possesseurs du
sabre noir etc en défaisant guidone ce
dernier fasse réunir les mandaloriens
dispersé je veux dire le sabre est un
patrimoine fort pour ce peuple un
symbole énorme qui fut malheureusement
volet side in le récupère et 20 biden ce
dernier serait un nouveau symbole pour
les mandaloriens celui qui ferait
renaître la flamme de ce peuple
malheureusement purger au cours de
l'histoire est bien évidemment comme
pour rob one
ce serait malheureusement une légende
peu connu mais forte et qui a amené la
victoire
[Musique]
pour conclure il est évident que nous
allons parler d'utilisateurs de la force
comme mentionné par l'armure hier et
guide des mandaloriens il existe un
peuple de sorcier manipulant les mêmes
pouvoirs que l'enfant ap les jedi
nous sommes dans star wars et si
scénaristiquement c'est une piste qui a
été présentée c'est que cela va arriver
d'ailleurs il est même dit que la saison
de deux mandats lauriane nous
présenterait un combat au sabre laser
pour le moment dans la série
seul mot vidéo nous a été présenté avec
un sabre donc il y aura certainement un
combat entre lui et possiblement un jedi
ou un autre utilisateur de la force et
c'est là que nous devons nous
questionner nous sommes environ cinq ans
après le retour du jedi luke est donc
toujours présent et il me semble qu'il a
même potentiellement commencé son
académie jedi
néanmoins à ce moment là qu'elle
lorraine vient juste de naître donc pas
vraiment sûr de cette info mais il est
dit dans star wars neuf qu'il s'était
entraîné avec les ja et qu'elle était
devenue une sorte de chevalier jedi nos
concrètement il se pourrait que les deux
personnages apparaissent à l'écran
néanmoins carrie fisher nous a
maintenant quitté et je ne suis pas sûr
que disney est encore la possibilité
d'utiliser sa personne pour faire
revenir les c'est une question très
compliquée donc j'aime et de gros doutes
le choix de luc en revanche est plus
pertinent car ce dernier a connu yoda et
scénaristiquement ce serait plus simple
et plus cohérent que ce soit ce dernier
qui aiderait le mandalorien à ce moment
précis l'udc n'est pas encore en pseudo
exil et il se peut que ce dernier soit
encore accessible pour autrui mais on en
revient à la technologie et choix
cinématographiques
est ce que disney a vraiment la
possibilité et l' envie de faire revenir
luc en jeunes pour un ou plusieurs
épisodes
surtout que l'udc est une légende
maintenant un personnage terriblement
populaire est ce que le faire passer au
second plan serait vraiment pertinent au
final et est-ce qu'on se raccrocherait
pas trop à l'histoire des skywalker une
fois de plus
cependant un autre cas de figure se
présente le personnage bien connu des
fans
ahsoka tano a de très grandes chances de
faire son apparition dans la série
c'est une ancienne jedi qui à la base
était l'apprenti d'anakin avant qu'ils
ne sont
cette dernière fait partie de la série
clone wars et star wars rebels qui sont
bien évidemment canon la pertinence de
ce personnage serait qu'elle n'est pas
encore apparue en tant que véritable
personnage de film soit qu'un acteur
enfin plutôt une actrice l'incarnant
gros de plus
ahsoka a connaissance du sabre noir et
il ya même été confronté il est donc
fort à parier qu'elle viendrait en aide
à jean jouines surtout que ces dernières
est également connue yoda enfin ce qu'il
serait très intéressant pour moi serait
de voir le retour du personnage de masse
kanata avec un raisonnement comme avait
eu en solo dans l'épisode 7
il se peut que le mandalorien se dirige
vers la planète de masse réputé pour en
savoir
énormément sur l'univers son histoire
est également la force étant une
utilisatrice neutre elle permettrait en
plus de ravir les fans d'expliquer la
nature de ce pouvoir a dit mme jeannine
et l'orienté pour la suite de sa quête
bien évidemment il y aura d'autres
nouveaux personnages dans la série et
nous sommes encore bien loin d'être au
bout de nos surprises
l'arrivée du personnage d'ahsoka peut
être vraiment très intéressant mais
j'espère qu'il ne créeront pas
d'incohérence par rapport à la nouvelle
trilogie
donc je suis curieux si cette vidéo vous
a plu n'hésitez vraiment pas à laisser
votre plus gros pouce bleus à un
commentaire en partageant vos idées vos
théories et surtout en vous abonnant à
cette chaîne
cela me prouve vraiment votre soutien je
suis très heureux d'enfin avoir pu
parler d'eux mandaloriennes avec vous en
espérant vous reparler de star wars très
bientôt
profitez bien de disney plus que le line
up soit avec vous c'était un roc
allez ciao tout
et b
fa non coëx